your brief now how are plans shaping out
for people being able to attend live
events in the summer
well we've set out a really ambitious
roadmap which we're working very hard to
deliver on so if all goes well and uh
vaccine remains on track as it is and we
keep the disease under control by the
17th of May we'll be back to the sort of
things that we saw last summer so
socially distance performances uh indoor
and outdoor and then the big step for
will be on the 21st of June which means
which will be the point at which we want
to get as much back as we possibly can
and I'm working really intensively to
work on the safest way to do that so
I've already announced uh Pilots for
example we're going to Pilot at the FA
Cup Final we're going to Pilot at The
Crucible we're looking at how we can
ensure in indoor and outdoor settings
how we can get as many people back as we
possibly can and get back to the things
we we really love as a nation
uh your quotas and papers today are
saying that your confident fans can pour
into Wembley with less or no social
distancing for the euros and that's
because of covid certification what what
exactly will be covered certificates and
what will that entail
well um from the 21st of June if it all
goes uh to plan in the way that I
described we hope to get uh people back
in significant numbers we're piloting
the different things that will enable
that to happen clearly it will have to
be done in a covered secure way so you
would expect and we'll be testing these
things things like one-way systems
things like masks things like hand
hygiene and everything else and as part
of that another thing that we are
considering is a covid certification and
we'll be testing whether we can use
covert certification to help facilitate
the return of sports obviously final
decisions have not been taken on that
and I'm working with Chancellor duchy of
Lancaster Michael gopu is leading on our
covert certification work program but I
think that is a potential that could
help the return of of the things that we
love but but what exactly will a covid
certificate be and how will that differ
from a vaccine passport say I mean
people will want to know the money of
what a certificate will mean
yeah and we are um we are working
through those details and we've already
said that we've got to review that
review as ongoing and we'll we'll
publish the review we've been clear that
there won't be a vaccine uh passport the
Prime Minister has
um made that very clear what we have
said though is that in order to to prove
uh for example that you've um had a
vaccine or that you've had a successful
negative test we'll we're looking at
ways to help facilitate proving that and
that may be one of the things that could
help ensure that we can get more people
back into stadiums but remember there's
there's sort of there's three tracks
going on here at the the same time one
and the most important thing of all is
that we continue to control this disease
that means everyone abiding by the rules
is working getting numbers down and the
risks taking their vaccine when they get
the the call up to do so we're making
good progress on that secondly uh the
chance of the duchy of Lancaster and the
others I'm I'm helping on the side this
is looking at different mitigations that
we could use including the the covered
vaccine
certification and I'm also through how
would somebody go about getting a covid
certificate how long would it last and
and how would you police that they have
actually gone through the right process
to get the certificate yeah and look
though those are all entirely legitimate
questions which is exactly why we have
set up this review and we're working
through the challenges to get that right
and what we said is that can potentially
be a tool that will enable people to
return but remember it will sit
alongside other things to make places uh
safe like one-way systems like hand
sanitizing and all of this is all
predicated on getting the the vaccine
rollout delivered and getting the
disease under control because it's only
if we do those things that we can even
start considering the kind of large
numbers of people returning that we so
desperately want from the 21st of June
and which I'm making my my number one
Mission I've been meeting uh several
times this week that's why we've got
Nick heidner a very famous theater
producer David Ross working with many
many people to see how we can get people
back safely in large numbers because if
we don't manage to do it if we don't
manage to do it this summer if we
succeed with the vaccine rollout if we
succeed in getting the disease under
control I'm really worried about the
future of those uh industries that are
so vital not just to our sense of
national well-being but to the whole
National economy
and do you envisage that there still
will be social distancing you're saying
that you want to get the maximum people
back into to stadia but will there be
social distancing
well I I hope we will be able to find
ways of mitigating against certainly
having the sort of social distancing
that we have at the moment because the
sort of social distancing we have at the
moment makes it very very difficult for
example for uh theater Productions to be
run profitably it makes it very very
difficult for our football clubs to um
to run profitably if you have to have
those large distances between people now
clearly we've been in this situation for
the past year where we've had to have
those distances so we are proceeding
with caution that's why it's the last
stage that's why we are piloting
different ways of mitigating against
that and as we've discussed one of the
things that we are considering as part
of that is covered certification
and can you guarantee what's open
football stadium and the like will be
able to remain open we have heard from
the scientists that when it comes to the
the winter months we might have to start
wearing masks again and then by
implications social distancing again
well that's why we are proceeding with
caution because we really want these to
be a permanent uh re-openings and one of
the things that I know that frustrated
people uh last year was not being able
to have that that sort of certainty
obviously as as you and your viewers
will appreciate this terrible disease
um has changed over time but we will be
we'll be doing everything we can to
ensure that it's it's pumped I'm sure
you'll appreciate the week we can't
foresee every um last eventuality but
what we are doing is trying to get the
conditions right so this this will be a
permanent reopening
um I wonder what you make of the
University of Warwick's modeling study
that's out today in which they say it's
um vaccinating all adults in the UK is
unlikely to achieve herd immunity and
fully contain the virus
well uh first of all vaccination has a
huge beneficial impact it has a huge
beneficial impact for the people taking
it it's the best way to to stop you uh
getting the disease and once you've had
two doses it is highly effective and
certainly if we as we get through the
the top uh nine categories and we're
confident we'll do that by mid April we
should see enormous reductions in
hospitalizations and
deaths every comment specifically on
their line that it it won't fully
contain the virus
um well the the evidence is emerging on
the effect of the vaccine on spreads so
we we don't know fully the picture I
think it will have a significant effect
on spread but no vaccine is going to be
perfect of course not you're not you're
not going to buy vaccine alone uh fully
prevent the spread of the disease but
the the sort of steps that we have
outlined have in mind that we
sufficiently reduce hospitalizations uh
reduce deaths so that we can live with
this disease over the coming years so
there won't be an elimination of the
disease but we should get to a point
where it is safe for most activities uh
to resume and that that is what the
roadmap is all about
and on the vaccines on the shortage can
you clarify exactly what the situation
is with the the lack of vaccines that
are coming from India
well I I think the Prime Minister and
the chief medical officer and health
secretary addresses yesterday there has
been a uh delay uh in respect to about
five million doses from the the serum uh
Institute in India they are doing a
fantastic job and working as as hard as
they can we always knew there were going
to be uh fluctuations in the vaccine but
we are confident on those landmarks to
reopening that we are on the right track
so we got the most at risk people
vaccinated uh by the middle of February
by the middle of April we want to get uh
all over 50s and uh the most vulnerable
vaccinated we're confident we're on call
so that once we've done that we really
will have a huge impact on reducing
deaths and hospitalizations and then by
the end of uh July we're still on track
for getting the rest of the adult
population vaccinated so you would
expect movements up and down a bit but
the overall trajectory were very much on
course with that